mon beau frère elle était arrêtée dans
une concentration quand pendant deux ans
lille et monaco l'est et là aussi il
était arrêté depuis septembre 2010 est
lui elle est mon ami l'élément cousins
sont tous arrêtés
dans l'éducation comme aujourd'hui je
vais vous parler des camps de détention
pour une gourde en chine plus d'un
million de personnes seraient
actuellement détenus dans ces camps et
voici l'une des rares vidéos de cette
réalité
des centaines d'hommes issus de cette
minorité musulmane menotté le crâne rasé
juste avant leur transfert en train vers
des camps de détention
répressions massives en chine et menace
en france à 7000 km la diaspora ouïgoure
vie aussi sous la pression du régime
chinois
irujo légitime potache coin chalet aux
fins d'une opa ou quatuor nintendo
koraichi sixième jeu reçu pas mal de
téléphone avec le numéro inconnu il ya
une mode dame chinoise n ai dit vous
avez un collet il faut retirer votre
coller sur l'ambassade de la chine en
france la majorité des ouigours en
france on a déjà reçu le même message
on a peur calais au bassin chinois bien
sûr si je suis allée ambassades chinois
dont ils vont m'arrêter bien sûr la
chine les mairies bien présente ici
camps de concentration comme au centre
de rééducation où on vit dans une
situation de éradication de l'identité
ouïghoure de la langue et de la culture
we do bon brut on a rencontré ces femmes
idylle bourg à la recherche de leurs
disparus et qui veulent alerter le monde
sur ces camps de la honte
depuis des semaines vous avez peut-être
vu passer ces vidéos de soutien au
peuple ouïghour comme par exemple cet
ado américaine de 17 ans qui a partagé
ce faux tuto maquillage vue des millions
de fois
mesut ozil la star du club de foot
anglais d'arsenal a lui aussi tweeté
contre le régime chinois décor ans ont
brûlé des mosquées détruites les écoles
islamiques interdite des frères envoyé
par la force dans des camps en
représailles le dernier match d'arsenal
a été interdit de diffusion en chine
[Musique]
cette répression de masse contre les
ouïghours en chine c'est aussi grâce au
travail du new york times qu'on en parle
aujourd'hui en novembre 2019
le journal américain a mis en ligne un
rapport secret sur le sort de cette
minorité
un rapport de 400 pages avec des ordres
très précis et un discours sans pitié
celui du président chinois xi jinping
pour lui il ne faut avoir absolument
aucune pitié avec les ouïghours il faut
utiliser les outils de la dictature
populaire pour éliminer l'islam radical
dans la province d'udine jambes
[Musique]
c'est à partir de cet argument là d'
attaque ne concernait qu'un petit nombre
de ouïghours que les autorités chinoises
ont décidé non pas de répondre de
manière ciblée pour adresser le problème
mais ont décidé de mettre en place une
campagne de répression de masse à
l'échelle de toute la province et à
l'échelle des 13 millions de ouïghours
et de musulmans qui vivent dans cette
province
la répression contre les ouïghours ça se
passe dans la province du jilin jien
[Musique]
non
les autorités chinoises prétendent qu'il
s'agit de caen d'apprentissage de
formation professionnelle et quand une
personne est arrêtée qu'elle est placée
dans ce camp qu'elle n'a pas le droit
d'en sortir et qu elle y subit toutes
formes de mauvais traitements qui
peuvent constituer même des actes de
torture on peut bien appeler ça des
camps de détention
mais qu'est ce qui se passe en réalité à
l'intérieur de ses camps il n'y a aucune
photo aucune vidéo pour répondre à la
question mais des milliers de
témoignages ont été compilées par des
ong
les anciens détenus racontent tous la
même histoire surpopulation maltraitance
et lavage de cerveau dans les centres de
détention est en place tout un programme
d'endoctrinement des personnes détenues
qui va aller de l'apprentissage forcée
du chinois mandarin à l'apprentissage de
chants patriotiques ou célébrant le
président xi jinping
tout un programme pour les faire devenir
ce que les autorités chinoises appels de
dons chinois loin du jing zhang à paris
j'ai rencontré des réfugiés ouïghours
qui vivent eux aussi sous les menaces du
gouvernement chinois
pouvant même message qu'elle a dit
le policier chinois qui sont demandées
mon adresse en france à paris quel
arrondissement j'habite qui a donc tué
les tâches car le bâtiment
si je refuse je perds que les policiers
chinois ils ont ils vont chercher des
problèmes avec mes parents
[Musique]
pendant cette vidéo ma mère il n'est
rien dire parce que parce que les peurs
qui part donc l ai écrit une lettre il
est dit que maintenant la policière
chinois ils sont bien sûr y est avec moi
et il faut arrêter parler avec les
médias il faut arrêter parler avec les
journalistes
sinon les chinois le policier aux
chinois ils vont m'arrêter sur cette
vidéo je peux sentir ma mère il est
vraiment dans vraiment dans une
situation très très pression très très
peur mama rosin elle est très peureux
j'ai pu m'entretenir avec d'ignorer jan
elle a créé des cours de culture et de
langue ouïghoure
c'est aussi une confidente pour les
familles de la diaspora à la recherche
de leurs disparus dans les camps chinois
[Musique]
ja recherche et de formation
y'a combien on est donc dans le mois
le maire
oh
[Musique]
soit il faut accepter d'être totalement
sinisé c'est à dire abandonner son
identité encore abandonné sa langue et
sa culture et sa croyance est d'adopter
seuls des chinois soit soit the se faire
enfermer ou alors pire se faire torturer
et disparaître deux semaines
c'est pourquoi maintenant si dans notre
responsabilité de transmettre notre
culture et notre langue à nos enfants
[Musique]
quand on aujourd'hui 450 figure de la
société ouigours qui sont dans ces camps
de concentration parmi eux trois
présidents d université ouigours sont
condamnés à mort du barreau de toucy
intellectuelle au vigan je pars en deux
et trois millions d'ouïghours dans
l'école mais ils ont pas la chance
d'entendre ou de savoir quelque part
dans le monde on parle d'eux mais
espérons qu'un jour ils vont à savoir
dans un monde libre
[Applaudissements]